[Music]
I want to talk about how our bodies are
designed to carry heavy stuff because
that was that was I did not know that
and you paint a really beautiful picture
in the comfort crisis you paint a
beautiful picture of all the rhetoric
the human body the humans are the
weakest animal we're lame we have no
horns we have no fur we have no muscles
were just weak wimps and you pointed out
not true there's one thing that we do
better than everything else every other
animal and I was like I and right when
you said it I was like yep that makes
perfect sense yeah um but that was new
for me yeah carrying carrying weight
across distance we're the only animal
that can carry loads across distance and
people will often say well what about
donkeys it's like well yes but the human
has to strap the load onto the donkey so
it's you know they can't do it uh by
themselves um and this totally shaped us
so the way that humans would hunt in the
past is we would slowly but surely run
down an animal uh and we'd bump it and
bump it and bump it because other
animals are not good at cooling
themselves we are so we sweat um all
these different things So eventually
this animal after we chased it for 10
miles it would become exhausted from the
heat it would fall over and then we
would spear it and then we would have
food right but we've got to take it back
to Camp so then what do you do you got
to carry that weight all the way back to
camp and this shaped Us full stop so you
can look at all these different
adaptations we have the reason we are
built the way we are is to carry things
long distances and still today and to
run long distances to get it right run
long distances to get it so in the book
I talk about it's like look people know
running is good for you like jogging's a
thing there are running stores all over
uh but how many people for a workout
carry weight for a significant distance
the answer is not many the um the sort
of tribe that still does is the military
so rucking is a found is the foundation
of training for basically all soldiers
especially Special Forces and rooking is
throwing some weight in the backpack and
basically going for a walk now the
reason that this is so good for people
is uh well there's a handful first of
all you're also working your strength as
you are doing cardio so you're getting a
two for One MH and this seems to
preferentially burn fat so there's some
really interesting studies on uh
Backcountry hunters and they basically
find that these guys will go out and
they don't have a ton of food and
they'll be out for a week but they're
rcking around with heavy backpacks on
their back and they come back back and
they've lost 10B or so but their muscle
has stayed the same wow if they were
running without the weight it would have
probably been about equal right yeah um
it's also a lot less injurious than
running so everyone's probably run and
afterwards you know your knee hurts or
your whatever you stopped running
because
XYZ um Rings injury rate is way lower
it's about the same as walking which is
if you can if you can walk you can rock
um the next question I always get yet is
how much weight should I use and I
always tell people start slow or start
low you know start with 10 15 lbs if
you're a bigger person maybe 20 see how
that feels add weight from there um
Don't Go Over a third of your body
weight though that seems to you get
diminishing returns the injury rate
starts to go up a little bit it's just
not really worth it what it for yeah
yeah that um I can think of no other
move in my life over the last 3 years um
that's made a significant contribution
to My overall health and fitness and it
gets me outside and it it gets me that
same burn I guess when you're lifting
weights but also gets the it's just
awesome and there's something I I don't
know if you experien this I take that
weight off and I can't describe it other
than I feel like a million bucks I just
feel so good and it's a strange I don't
know if it's just psychosomatic I don't
know what it is but I just feel right
when I throw that backpack off and it's
I'm tired but it's just it's just right
yeah and the the other reason I love it
too is you can do it with people other
people yeah so if you're running one
person is going to have like if I want
to go for a run with my mom who's 73
like first of all she's not going to
want to run but if she does I'm going to
basically be in a fast walk and I'm not
getting a great workout if I want to
rock with my mom I could throw in 45 lbs
she could have a 5B plate and we'd go at
the same speed and we'd get a pretty
equal effect and we can have a
conversation we can connect we can do uh
all these things that humans are
basically born to do yeah which is go
out into nature together do something
physical have a conversation while you
do it I mean it's just you're ticking so
many boxes that are good for people
that's been transformative quite
honestly um Michael Easter the marriage
counselor for my marriage and it started
about two years ago with hey let's just
go go for a walk we live out in the
country let's just go for a walk and I
was got antsy and it was about an hour
or two hour walk I got ansy so then the
next time I just threw my backpack on
with my wife and we have fought we have
wept together over the last two years we
have solved big issues in our marriage
we have planned vacations and trips and
what are we going to do about schools
we've had some really intimate time
and I get to have 35 or 45 pounds in my
backpack while we're walking and so I'm
getting a good exercise and it's double
and triple and quadruple dipping and
when you're a dad and you got two kids
and you have a full-time job and she's
running those hours become sparse and
man it's been such a gift to our
marriage that we can go at the same Pace
yet have two different things
metabolically going on in our bodies at
the same time it's been
incredible last thing I want to cover
um and I couldn't I couldn't believe it
when I read it in scarcity brain you
like me don't land on a here's the
step-by-step path for spirituality but I
felt like we both landed in in the same
place that you have to take a need of
something bigger than you is happening
and if you find yourself at the center
of the universe that's almost the
Bedrock for addiction it's almost the
Bedrock for misery which is everything
revolves around me walk me through how
you landed from cuz you you you mean you
started in Baghdad and you end up in New
Mexico and I end up in a doctor's office
and end up at a Mexican food restaurant
with a monk like and we both end up in
almost the same place walk me through
how you got from there to there and then
how do you think about this idea of
submission or sitting in the presence of
something bigger than you yeah that's a
great question
um I'll tell you this the night before I
got sober one of my best friends goes do
you believe in God and I said dude if
someone needs a set a rules a Hocus
Pocus rules to live a good life and be a
decent human that person is full of it m
so I you know I say that and then I go
out to the bars and behave like a
complete idiot so you can see how far my
head was up my butt in that situation I
wake up and for whatever reason I tried
to quit drinking tons and tons of times
many times and for whatever reason that
morning I could just see down field we
like if you keep drinking that'll solve
your problems in the short term over
time but you're going to die early full
stop or you can take the second path
which is to get sober and it's going to
be the hardest thing you ever do but on
the other side of that I felt like there
was something there so I like to say
it's almost like God heard my lines the
night before and went yeah watch this
sucker hold my
beer and uh after I got sober uh I do I
do think there was something higher at
play I just I just feel that way um and
that changed my thinking and getting out
of myself a key for me to stay
sober is to do things to get out of
myself and um my experience is in from
reporting the Comfort crisis to
reporting scarcity brain and traveling
have very much
been trying to unpeel that onion which
is very complicated right these are
questions that everyone has been
grappling with for a very long time all
time yeah and I think I've basically
just landed on the fact that I
personally my idea of spirit uality I
believe there's absolutely something
higher than myself bigger than myself
there's some higher order to all this at
the same time I don't have to understand
it I can be okay with being like you
know what I don't know exactly what it
is um and I'm also extremely respectful
of anyone who all religions if you feel
like you uh know what works great I'm
not going to argue with anyone like that
like I just I just have a lot more um
empathy and respect for people and
trying to do the next right thing like
the sort of Monk said has enhanced my
life full stop more
importantly the lives of those around me
so when I get sober it's not just that
like oh great Michael's you know not
going to die at 45 or whatever it is
it's that now all of a sudden my
girlfriend has a better life in turn her
family has a better life in turn the
people they work with have a better life
like there are big down effects from
that sort of uh decision and I've also
noticed that when I start to fall back
to not doing the next right thing that
sort of reverses course and it's a good
reminder that um you know it is this
sort of constant battle and if I can say
anything about what I've learned along
the way is that it's a battle everyone's
fighting you know and you can see once
people start to really focus on
themselves not only do they start to
become more likely to be miserable but
so do the people in their orbit mhm and
do you want that yeah no and I also
don't think there I find that there is
zero correlation between wealth and um
living a good life like full stop I've
been to countries where people have like
I go to Bhutan right there's not a
stoplight in a single country in the
country in the whole country there's not
a Starbucks there's not a McDonald's um
people aren't walking around on iPhones
mhm they're the happiest people I've
ever encountered the nicest The Joy
they're present um and it's one of the
least developed countries on Earth by
GDP and so I really think that you know
the battle for us today is um realizing
that we are surrounded in such abundance
and opportunity and uh wealth and just I
mean it's an amazing time to be alive it
really is but I think that comes with
perils too where we can start to you
know Focus more on getting the next
thing and not as much on sharing and
trying to help others and um that was a
long rambling way of answer I love it I
appreciate that that's awesome I think
that bringing your eyes out of your own
belly button changes everything yeah hey
man this is fun I appreciate you being a
good friend and you've been a big help
to me behind closed doors and so I'm
grateful to you and um
Everybody if you don't have this book in
Your Hands by the end of this interview
you're doing something wrong with your
life and I I I I don't say that lightly
um please go pick this up and if you
have to choose between this one and you
haven't bought mine yet buy this one
first get this book scarcity brain from
the great Michael Easter thank you so
much my brother I'm grateful for you I'm
G to disagree with that you did a you
did you did an amazing job on your book
very helpful I've had family members who
literally sent me a picture of it
because I had the little blurb they you
blurb this I read this book and it's
helped me well I appr full stop so nice
work man thank you
man